i've just had a phone call from a senior
mp from the northeast of england who
says that
22 mps from the northeast labour and
conservative
were called to a meeting with nadine
doris minister of state at the
department of health
and she's told them the government will
tomorrow announce uh lockdown
restrictions for in seven local
authority areas in the northeast of
england
coming into force at midnight uh
thursday friday
the seven authorities affected are
newcastle
northumberland north tyneside south
tyneside
gateshead county durham and sunderland
that is a large part
not all of the population of england the
restrictions will include
no socializing with anyone from a
different household
at 10 pm curfew and on pubs
and or no no travel apart from essential
travel
what are the numbers in terms of
infections um
well they uh they have been some of
those authorities
south tyneside sunderland gateshead and
newcastle
have already been on a government watch
list which means the numbers have been
going up
in quite an alarming way um now
at the meeting mps said well if you're
going to bring in these restrictions
what about testing in the northeast of
england
now the mps i've spoken to the mp i've
spoken to so far
uh says that they were very unimpressed
by the answers they got from the dean
doris
on plans for more testing in the north
east of england there's also concern
about the amount of communication
between the government and the local
authorities so far
the mps have been called in and told but
there's some concern that the
local authorities have not had enough
information from the government but just
to confirm
mr hancock is due to make a common
statement tomorrow on coronavirus
seems certain that this is going to be
what he's going to announce and the
rules will come in
midnight thursday night friday morning
midnight thursday night in seven local
authorities seven in the northeast okay
john thank you very much
john craig